the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys before start with a new theory I'd
like to thank you for all support you
gave so far 12 you 4,600 subscribers and
to all of you who are not subscribed
subscribe if you enjoy our videos it
would mean a lot thank you for taking
your time supporting us today I'm going
to talk about the fate of ginjury the
guy whose fate was unknown after
escaping from the island of Dragonstone
with the help of third IOC word Joe
Dempsey a keg injury has been firstly
spotted on September of 2016
spotted by a fan in or nylund's Belfast
City Airport ginjuries appearance in
season 7 was confirmed a few months ago
with a lot of leaked photos of him at a
filming that took place on Murray Ola
beach in Baraka Joe Dempsie the actor
that plays ginjury appeared on filming
set on Mariola beach in ba Rica the
leaked photo shows a double sink injury
were probably at King's Landing and were
together preparing the boat to leave but
all the sudden two gold cloaks
approached that was then in favour to
avoid a conflict demonstrating to them
that the boat is instantly empty by
pulling back the tarp that was also
bribed the gold cloaks who turned to
leave but just then Tyrion showed up and
passed by them the gold cloaks spotted
Tyrion and came back immediately
perhaps they recognized the most famous
dwarf in the Seven Kingdoms or they just
suspected that it might be Tyrion
Lannister owls try to avoid the possible
conflict by tried talking to them but
the gold cloaks grab their swords that's
the moment when ginjury reacted picked
up his Warhammer from the boat and
struck them from behind whereupon Davos
Tyrion egg injury which the both
offshore and headed to Dragonstone let
me just say that it's not surprising
that ginjury will be at King's Landing
in the first episodes of season 7
considering the last scene of ginjury in
which that was saved him from being
burnt alive by sending him to King's
Landing in a rowboat and told him to
keep Rowan until he comes to King's
Landing on the chicken jury at first
said that the gold cloaks are looking
for him
boiling that he wouldn't be safe over
there but the house convinced him that
he is going to be safe since the gold
cloaks don't know how he looks like now
when most of main characters are in
Dragonstone
for instance Daenerys Missoni Varys
Tyrion reformed Jon Snow Dallas team
rage
ginjury and Jorah next one we are going
to see is a few of them preparing to
leave from leaked photos we can see
juror who will also come at Dragonstone
while it's unknown if he cured his
greyscale whereupon miss all talking
scene between him and the nearest in
which Danny says farewell to her advisor
who in return vows to his queen as the
single zone the nearest turns to Jon
meanwhile Jorah helps some man to
prepare the boat this man as we can see
in the photos are Davos and ginjury the
scene doesn't surprisingly as Jon Davos
girag injury push the boat and went to
get away now what everyone wants to know
is Verdi going my first thought is north
beyond the wall asleep but says that
John Willie Jorah Davos sang ginjury
together with the Hound two brothers
without banners torment and a few
brothers from Night's Watch
a team that is going to try catch a
white in favor to bro Daenerys and show
the rest of Westeros real danger that
threatens them there are some proofs
they're going in favor to this theory
I've already said a lot about these
proofs for this theory few weeks ago so
today I'll tell your shorter version in
case you didn't watch my previous videos
Game of Thrones crew have been quietly
constructing a large snow is set at
valle hill quarry in the hills above
Balthus crew has blanked the area with
fake snow and created an artificial icy
surface rather like an iced over lake
you can also still large green screen
with snowing ground beneath it a nice
location point to season seven
taking us beyond the wall and kind of
support the theory as I've said my
thoughts are that they are going to be
on the wall which feeds the ice location
that the crew is trying to make as best
as they can also in link plot there's
mentioned that Jon and his team will get
a tag by night king's army while they
are trying to catch white in details
ders described that they are going to be
attacked on the icy surface by undead
army and white polar bear in which one
brother without banners is going to get
killed
apparently ginjury in the most of John's
team actually all of them will be say by
Daenerys central dragon swallow she will
manage to save John John will almost get
killed while being surrounded by the
Horde of White Walkers and whites when
all the sudden benjin will appear and
save his nephew by the league plot Ben
general said when a journalist
were sent seven while he'll stay and
fight as long as he can and iced over
Lakes going round with fake snow when
the icy surface that the crew had made
seems that it perfectly fades in liquid
besides there's some hard proof as we
head to relief photos in first one we
can see the unit two white walkers
Cindy's crewmates said which they were
preparing for a few weeks for the
shooting three hundred extras had been
brought on this icy sad
which makes this theory almost hundred
percent true the second photo also goes
in favour to this theory as we can see
three characters that had never crossed
paths in previous seasons but are now
together just like Yuri says and guess
where are they dared Belfast the
location where the crew had been
preparing a nice set for a few weeks the
third photo would also go in favour to
this theory but disliked photos quality
is way to allow in our opinion it's John
preparing for filming on this icy set
but since the quote is to allow I can
guarantee you guys if it's Jon Snow
about a month ago
I've said that we're only waiting for
Emilia Clarke to appear in Belfast which
would be the final confirmation for this
theory well we were waiting for Emilia
to appear in Belfast for about months
ago but we don't have to wait anymore
since she appeared in Belfast few days
ago which I have to admit is the final
confirmation for this theory we won't
have any leaked photos of Emilia Clarke
aka Daenerys from filming set since she
will film her scenes only cited Titanic
Studios all of this confirms that
ginjury will finally get his role in the
upcoming seasons which I must admit is
not surprising at all injuries the last
living son of King Bryan he's a bastard
so he doesn't have his father's surname
but he didn't either receive the bastard
surname that is used in the Crown lands
which is waters because he was not
openly acknowledged by Robert in my
opinion ginger will have much bigger
role in season 8 much bigger than he is
going to have in the upcoming season
while other people are talking about
possibility of ginjury meeting Arya at
Winterfell since he is the part of John
steamed is going north beyond the wall
my opinion on that is absolutely no Jon
ginjury Davos and Jorah will travel by
the scene the boat as you can see from
leaked photos meaning that they won't
make a step on the ground before they
make it to the wall meaning the devil
travel to eastwatch-by-the-sea
eastwatch-by-the-sea is the castle and
port located at the far eastern end on
whoa
where do all drops into an inlet of the
Shivering sea called the bay of seals
eastwatch-by-the-sea is one of the only
treem and castles left on the wall along
with Castle black and the shadow tower
that's the place on the John will gather
his team and go on white hunting
well apparently Davos will stay over
there and wait in the novel's its
specified at King Stannis Baratheon also
landing with his forces at East which by
the sea when he came to the world to
save the Nights Watch in my opinion
ginjury who is known as a skilled
blacksmith will be very important in
season eight since I'm expecting from
Sam to find out how to make water in
steel a formal medal that was forged in
the days of the mighty Valyrian freehold
I'm expecting from Sam to find out how
to make it violence at Citadel and I'm
also expecting from ginjury to make
swords of Valyrian steel do happen that
the living sign desperately needs the
only weapon that can besides the
dragonglass killed White Walkers we have
a few leaked photos of John Bradley
known as saml Tarly which were taken
from filming set at casseras photos in
which Sam is leaving the old town with
to Gilly and baby Sam which could mean
that the same at this point we'll
already learn how to make Valyrian steel
since these scenes of Sam are going to
be placed in either episode 4 or episode
5 which I know for sure since on the
filming set director Matt shack man was
spotted back in the third season when
Melisandre bought ginjury from the
Brotherhood without banners ginjury
disappointed that Brotherhood sold him
to Melisandre said that he thought he
was one of them he said that he thought
that he was the part of the Brotherhood
without banners on which Melisandre
replied with you are more than they are
ever going to be because viewed the
kings will rise and fall
let me repeat one part of a lissandra
sentence the Kings will rise and fall
because of you I'm aware the Melisandre
by this was pointing on his blood which
used for blood ritual but what if
Melisandre was wrong as she was wrong
welcome miss in Stannis that he was the
Promised One
what if she was right about part of
sentence in which she said that the
kings will rise and fall because of him
but what if she means the true meaning
of that what if the Kings will litter
rise and fall because of him as a result
of his own act good for an example
ginjury caused the fall of the knight
King by forging Valyrian steel sword
could the last living son of King Robert
Baratheon be brought back to do
something big something that will save
the whole Westeros let me know your
opinion in the comment section down
below
in conclusion ginger will definitely
appear in the upcoming season at his
father's Warhammer while in my opinion
he's going to play a much bigger role in
the last eight season also let me remind
you that we've started a giveaway in
which one lucky winner will receive $50
Amazon gift card all you have to do is
to click the link which is in the
description down below subscribe leave a
like or comment something nice hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
time peace
[Music]
you
[Music]